all right hello to people who are
joining us
uh for the second of our design review
live streams today we are
looking at features that will be going
into often language version
uh 12.3 and we had started
uh previously looking at geometry and
graphics
and we are continuing with that so let's
see where have we got to so far
we were talking about material shading
is that correct have we finished
material shading or not
unless you wanted to look at the namings
let's have a quick look at that
i know what i realized is this this
weird um
spinning has something to do with 12.3
some twelve point three front understeer
okay so which option should i be looking
at here this is the
those are the the parameterized model
okay based color coat color
why isn't it coating color
i mean it's like the things wearing a
big fur coat or something
um well in this case it's more generally
the clear coat right you have on top of
like a car
paint but you have a clear coat and then
you have to
i see
but how does it i mean if if it's
covering the surface how do you see
through it
and there's no i don't understand
but so usually you have the material
have the base color
right and you know for like for a card
the capping then you have kind of
in some case trillian right so you have
a clear coat on top
and then you have the color and then you
have a primer but in our case we just
have a clear coat
and then the base color so the clear
coat is roughly speaking transparent it
does have a reflection of the diffusing
light
the the the coat color you're saying is
transparent
yes but when is the code color not
transparent and why doesn't the coat
color
just change the effective base color
yeah if it actually affect the base
color it affect the amount of
light which reached the base color
that's pretty much it
but you're saying that it affects light
that is shining on the thing
does not get to the base color it gets
only to the coat color is that right no
it's
some of the light not the full set so
the clear coat reflects some of the
light
okay in this picture uh we don't have
the clear coat there
so we haven't yet completed so what we
are hoping is to actually have
to remove the clear coat and the sheer
color and have a second illustration
which
actually that additional layer you have
on top
so we are still working with team on
that illustration
okay okay well these seem like
reasonable names
what do you mean metallic values
um and what do you mean roughness values
what does that mean
well it's pretty much a numerical value
which is
priced to probably speaking a degree of
roughness or metallicness of an object
so
zero that means pretty much no metallic
not metallic
and one sorry yeah and one is metallic
so the non-dielectric are you know
less than one pretty much shouldn't it
be called metallic and then some word
that means parameter or coefficient
um yes you can probably say maybe
coefficient
the our coefficient seems right
it's a coefficient because it can it can
go with other things presumably
okay
surface normals is a bunch of normal
vectors right
yes so we name that
when you say roughness coefficient
what does that metallic coefficient
has to do with that sort of a bank
switching of specularity and various
other things correct
yes
okay is it
is coefficient right or is there some
other more slightly more technical term
you know metallic strength or i don't
know what
yeah usually people just say metallic or
roughness value
maybe we should call it metallic value i
just think metallic is a really weird
option name when the
when the value is 0.5
that's what i'm saying if we call it
roughness maybe it should call
metallicness
metal city that's what you call it for
stars
i see i didn't know that
what's the fraction of every elements in
a star
not relevant to this
but i mean it isn't a roughness i don't
know what scale you would measure
roughness i mean roughness of one means
what
can i have a roughness of four
charles can i have a roughness of four
or not um yes so it is a numerical value
between zero and one
also so you can't have a roughness of
four
oh you can't i mean
we can probably take it and then mod it
to adjust it but
it should be the value between the
question of the metallic fractional
roughness fraction
if it's between zero and one
does that make sense
i don't know what these things are i
mean they contribute obviously to some
some equation um
right so it's essentially it's kind of a
coefficient in the question
of the you know computation of the light
right depending on the specular light or
the fish light there is a coefficient
linear coefficient actually in that
equation which is reflected
roughness of the material or the level
of
conductivity of the material
um so wait a minute
okay listen what is the word that should
go with it is it metallic fraction
metallic coefficient
italic value roughness
value roughness
coefficient what do you think it should
be coefficient is sounding right for
what you're describing
right now yes especially that you know
we
you know in the technical document we
are going you know alex is white
writing now you know which kind of show
the question is the coefficient
term in data great okay we're done with
that then
specular anisotropy wait a minute
is that a value from zero to one or
something or what is that
um yes so that one is also a value
between the one one okay you shouldn't
call it property h
to say anisotropy of specular reflection
shouldn't you yes
although what does it mean isotropin how
do you measure anisotropy
i mean the the light is coming in at a
particular angle
and it will be specular reflection at
some other angle if the anisotropy is
0.7 what does that mean
um well again i mean
0.76 here is just like like above it's
just a coefficient right you know people
can use to vary to actually be able to
reproduce that effect of life or
simulate that effect of flight
so it's you should probably show it
specular anisotropy coefficient
i think because i think it's not
you know these are actual colors right
yes
and these are so there's a big there's a
there's a big deal um
that's that's these people discuss you
know that are
big into sort of modeling lighting
interaction
so they talk about physical parameters
and artist parameters
yes and they very much dislike physical
parameters
because they're not predictable what
they affect they have
and so they're striving for
parametrizations that can be sort of
predicted the effect that they have
yes and that's usually called artists
parametrization i didn't i i knew there
was a need for such a term like 30 years
ago
i i didn't know a term had a risk yeah
right yeah
so these guys are i mean i completely
understand where they're coming from it
makes perfect sense
because you might have two that sort of
co-interact and you can't really
tweak one without the other and it's
like horrible
well so specular anaesthetic coefficient
do you have a problem with that
no okay no the names are fine
i'm just saying that they're not as
physical as you might think
sometimes because people don't really
like the physical
right good reason to say coefficient so
ambient occlusion
well if it's the fraction ambient
occlusion fraction is it physical or
is it again an ambiguous occlusion
occlusion coefficient
or is it ambient occlusion fraction
well so in in this case the ambient
occlusion there is a fraction case which
applied globally to the
surface but you can actually apply it um
you know per point on the on the surface
so it's a fraction of the light on the
surface
so wait a minute this the value of this
is like 0.7 or something
right why between zero and one
okay and so then
is it okay tell me what it does again
what does it do fractions the ambient
light on the surface
you mean oh okay it's it's pretending
that you're shielded from the ambient
light
yes i see
well i mean i think it should be called
ambient occlusion fraction
that make sense unless you think it can
do without the fraction part
um well
both work for me i mean people are
usually just saying ambient occlusion
so but yes we cannot fraction
we don't have so many options you know
let me point out that occlusion
if it's equal to one that means there's
no ambient light
is that correct
um yes alex is that correct right
in this case it's actually the reverse
so one more
zero okay so then the name is wrong
because occlusion you have more
occlusion if the value is higher
which means that you have less
ambient light contributing
right yes
so is there any other name that people
use in the literature
either that or is this basically is this
the right way around i mean
or should it be zero one flipped around
we kind of need to know what people do
in the literature so come back with this
please
go ahead what are we going to say but i
think maybe it's the
the concept which is the order we are on
because it's more do
how i suppose a point right in the scene
is to an ambient light it's not
basically a
amount of ambient light but it's how do
you know
how i suppose a point in the scene so if
the value is higher if it's one
it gets all the ambient light no they're
saying it's the other way around
but then it's correct yes okay so wait a
minute
if the value is one does it get all the
ambient light yes
okay did you say yes or no i couldn't
hear you said yes yes
yes it's it's the wrong way around and
then it's the wrong way around yeah
no maybe we should change the order then
you know
you should take one minus that parameter
now if you stay down the end like
ambient occlusion is one that means the
point is fully exposed to the light no
but occlusion
means look we're not ray tracing here
occlusion
i thought it meant
look if you called it ambient exposure
fraction or something
then then what you're saying would make
sense
but the occlusion fraction is it's in
the light
and it's making a shadow for something
else but we don't have shadows
so that's not really relevant right
but if you call the ambient exposure
fraction
then that would handle it then that
would make clear
that it is the extent to which it is
exposed to the ambient light
which is kind of what you're going for
also with a seclusion idea
except that the occlusion idea makes
more sense if
the thing is going to you know cast a
shadow or whatever
does this make sense
um yes we kind of dig more in that yep
okay so ambient exposure fraction
makes sense yes
okay all right
question from the live stream from ethan
will be able to specify
shaders for materials in top level code
and currently support for
glsl code strings what is glsl
it's their shading language in opengl ah
okay so what's the answer will there be
any way to specify
shaders from top level um
not at this point so we we hope in
future version
to actually be able to import it um
we are still discussing that shader
language in general from
ultimately from compiled code or
something
um well first of all we want to be able
to import this materialx because that's
more composite
well-designed material
which i'm saying you need
um the shader language is very low level
so they've created a higher level
language which is this material x
modeling language effectively
which which uses these um
uh transfer functions these bound
these uh reflectance and transmission
transfer functions
effectively and or really approximations
to those
so then you can design all kinds of
layered material
and so we want to be able to import
those kinds of specs
and maybe even export them those kinds
of specs
okay so then we can then we can co then
we can
coexist together with other
digital content creation software both
cad software
and a sort of game software yeah i
understand
okay so materialx is so when you import
that
you will have something that is called
essentially you know
it will it look like material shader of
file of blah
or no it has to have some serializable
version
so it has to have some kind of uh
symbolic representation of that
imported actually you know what we have
this new
notion of an imported object
oh no x what is it called
yeah i think that's what it's called
imported object that we're using for
things like
pem files where there's some random
piece of external gunk
that is basically only relevant if you
feed it back to the outside world
you see what i'm saying i see so that
would be the relevant thing and
important
in here i'm not 100 i don't know enough
whether we have sorted everything out
because we use different rendering
systems on different hardware
so like
you know like apple wants to use methyl
for instance and
yeah i understand i understand so so the
import but i mean this is the same as
the compiler the situation we have with
the compiler
where it's generating code and now we
have a version where it serializes for
all the different platforms
and it just uses whichever serialization
is relevant
but if you tell it okay when you first
do the serializat when you first create
the compiled code function
you will be able to tell it what target
systems you want it to
to be set up for if you say target
systems to all
then it will try and do uh it will try
and build
you know the bag of bits for all the
systems we support and then for any
specific system
like a windows machine or something like
that
it will if it is read back in it will
rehydrate
just the windows version does that make
sense
yeah so i mean this would be presumably
the same kind of thing
and and in that case for some kinds of
extremely
you know close to the metal things we
will have compilation as a service
where it works through the cloud to
compile for all those platforms because
it actually has to send it
to actual machines with actual uh
libraries running on them and so on to
get
the final bag of bits so to speak but
fortunately we figured out a way to do
that using llvm intermediate code
that doesn't require one to go all the
way well it doesn't require one to do
that compilation as a service
so i don't know what exists in this case
between these different we have a little
bit more work to do so i don't really
want to
okay fine all right sounds good this
looks great
epi on our live stream is commenting
that ambient occlusion is the technique
the exposure is the value at the point
so the exposure is what we are recording
here right
right okay good stuff
well done anything else on material
shaders
material shading going once gone
okay let's continue here graph layout
oh good we've got method pages for those
now
is that what you're telling me yes
uh don't forget by the way i'm sorry
don't forget that you need one of those
if you need a guide page for the methods
and you need a um
list of graph layout methods thing and
the documentation at the top
right right so we are still working
on that actually okay all right so can i
click on one of these and see
see the page they're probably not linked
but you can you can open one
spring electrical should be probably an
example
okay how do i open it i think that this
one doesn't have any docker tool support
yet to do method pages
i think that we probably want to get
that now because we have several teams
working on it
so you have to bring up okay this is too
complicated
if you want to send me a page you can go
ahead and send me email the page
okay so what so what all should i see
so the main change here is just
documentation is that correct yes
okay when do we get things like
hyperbolic layout well
that's also there if you go select
slightly farther down
oh cool
where oh there we go cool cool i want to
see that okay hold on
okay so let me say oh this is really
cool am i going to be excited by this or
that's or is it going to have some
horrible problem okay so let's have a
carry tree
okay there's the carry tree but now if i
say graph of that
graph layout arrow
you know it will be just well i guess
hyperbolic right
what is it called
what happened um what fashion are you
guessing
you want to share or you want to send me
a send me a notebook where this has been
run
um but my stuff i complete have a new
build so i will try
something
it is a graph in autograph 3d right
actually try maybe the 3d maybe we
haven't done the full
embedding yet
no i mean it's just not working
it doesn't work on my builds
well just send it to me okay
are you sending it to me or not um yes
i'm sent to
okay all right
okay okay
okay i assume layered graph plot 3d is
comes with i mean that's the equivalent
of layered digraph
graph 3d of layered digar formatting is
that correct
um yes
okay what happened there
what what happened there can you hear me
i mean
what what what what is this
charles are you there yes yes so it's
those parts we are still
um you know what here because there is
the
you know right now we are not sorting
the the edge
to you know to allow those uh basically
non-crossing so that it lay correctly in
the
space if you are just purely embedding
the point so that's why i say cylinder
development so we are working on
actually that
acidic side and make sure everything is
you know okay
is there a parameter to the hyperboloid
so to speak to the hyperbola or
is there a parameter that determines i'm
i'm a little bit unclear what
isn't there some curvature parameter
here
for the curvature of the space
and no you know what kids we don't
but do you want to see that go ahead
so in our case you assume you're on the
point
um disk and essentially what we do is we
run the spring electrical and try to
force the point to
satisfy the constraint on that space
okay but i think that has a parameter i
mean i know the point gray disk itself
does not
but there's a question of kind of you
know if you imagine
you know one of those poincare disc
things that's kind of like how
clumped up is it at the at the boundary
that's a parameter which is essentially
the curvature i think
yeah so we probably have assumed that so
we can i can probably you know check
more and you know
and have that parameter yeah okay
cool all right let's keep going
all right so graph constructor
illustrations
lovely
find click and so on i'm sure that's
useful
are you putting these on the guide pages
as well
um not at this time i think we should
eventually do what we did for our biz
pages yeah so we created this new
constructor
for guide pages that goes through the
build system
uh it allows us to have visualizations i
mean or icons basically in there
but it's it's a it's a big development
project in its own right to do so we
okay doing it named labelled
why is it called named labelled yeah if
you have a better name
so it's
we have index labeled which was actually
when we introduced you was under your
request
until now okay so let's say it's not
even
index labeled okay oh that's nice
well here the index match with the name
i understand i understand so that's
not very exciting well named
labelled is clearly wrong it might be
name
labeled am i making sense
yeah didn't someone's saying because
because i mean in in in graph
if i say um
uh vertex labels
arrow and it's called name
right did you understand yes
so i mean that's what confused me if it
said name labeled i would have
understood it what it was
i just didn't understand name.labeled
and obviously the autocomplete for the
plot theme has to include stuff like
this
seems good to me okay
find spanning tree from list of
coordinates presumably returning the
coordinates again right
um but yeah it computes the equilibrium
span mean twice
essentially just spamming through
the smallest uh i i get it i understand
i'm asking
if you give it a list of coordinates
it turns to a graph with those embedding
coordinates
right okay but but
what was it doing i mean find spanning
tree before
didn't work for a list of coordinates
yeah i was just taking a graph
right i see so if i say find spanning
tree
of geo position well yeah geo position
capital cities in europe
interesting so now that okay so now if i
say
don't we have this geograph thing now
yes what can i
what can i type here geography to that
okay how come
well they should be
uh they're well it's i think it's a
constancy
we you know those your positions are
probably written has
annotations
well i think you've got something to
figure out here
but what's it doing in the layout here
like if i say vertex coordinates um
right so this layout is how do i get the
vertex coordinates
out of this uh graph embedding
but then i have to specify i see graph
embedding in percent eight
comma two dimensions yes yes
okay what's going on here what do you
mean comma two
oh it's come out the projection and
comment yes
oh i see okay so this
there those are geo positions except
they're not
um no they are not actually your
position they are just
the position from a spring electrical
embedding
we don't
one of those naxa whatever those things
are called
the the what are they in peru or
something
we don't really have okay so we don't
really have graphs and geo
interoperating that's something we need
to
figure out more fundamentally fair
enough
i mean there's things that you can
accidentally make
work if you do vertex replace
um but the fact that that works
is well is more accident barely works
right i mean it's more an accident than
that okay designed to work by the way
we added the new icelandic volcano to
geo data
the answer is probably yes this is
completely the wrong group to be asking
that of but um
uh somebody should should send i think i
heard yazoo
maybe you could send mail and check that
sure that would presumably go to alan or
francisco or somebody
um also you were trying to say something
no i see i mean
that should be close right i mean that's
an expected feature of the spring
electrical
right you'll be close to the real real
one but you will not be
much in term of length
oh wait but wait a minute you told me
that the spanning tree
on coordinates would preserve the
coordinates
in other words it generates the topology
of a spanning tree
but it still preserves the actual
coordinates
of the original points right in the case
where i feed in coordinates it should be
returning this
with the coordinates being the
coordinates of the original points
right yes if the if they are
coordinating
i understand i understand how do i get
the coordinates
um in the from geo position do you know
um no
i know this will work but it's kind of
hacky
[Music]
fine spanning tree expects a graph
except it doesn't now expect to graph so
you should change that message
did you understand what i'm saying yes
oh gosh there's a way to get these out
from geo position but i've now forgotten
um
okay here we go so now if i say
find spanning tree
okay and now if i say for that
right now i'm saying graph embedding of
that
oh and it's not going to be very useful
it's just going to put those back and
so now i just don't know which city is
which here right
that's a spanning tree of the cities in
europe probably
i'm guessing that's been flipped around
but i don't have any way to plot this do
i on
or does geograph plot plot this
i mean it needs geo coordinates
i mean geo position and so on you know
what it should default
geograph plot if you give it something
that just has pairs like this
it should assume they're geo positions
why not
okay you see what i'm saying and then
because that will give us some
interoperability even before we have the
full thing
why is there no raft coming up here
that's some other bug
see that anybody see that
that one is a raft oh the raft
raft okay by the way two bugs that raft
has its lower you know one of its
sides is missing there see that if you
can capture that
hear that anybody do that yes yes i did
i did um
and uh and down here for some reason
there's no raft coming up at all
no idea why it's probably a bug
associated with this this um
uh thing right below it either that or
there's some other
issue oh you know what it could be is
that this function is not yet
somehow in some table yeah look at that
it's not there yeah it's still futurized
okay that's the reason it didn't have a
raft
um okay
yeah this should work
right displays the graph g with vertices
at geographic locations
on the map if those vertex names
are geopositioned then it should work
and if those vertex
names if the vertex positions are like
this it should work
make sense yeah okay
vertex in component
so it's a stephen request
um oh vertex and component graph the
graph as opposed
to yeah i don't understand what you mean
by graph value from it doesn't have a
value
it's just a list of it's just a list of
vertices otherwise
this is the graph that represents its in
component
yeah that's what i'm saying the graph
the value is a graph
i didn't understand the phraseology
graph value right right
sorry okay vertex transitive graph q
great
edge transitive graph q terrific okay
oh really well so this isn't made it in
yet
this has not made it in yet the basic
research has been done but it has not
been
so here's the thing with the asymptotics
for number theoretic functions
we've been trying to the sort of a
multi-stage
multi-phase project and we're trying to
curate
what's there it's not as impressive as
you think
of what's known asymptotically hold on
how do i get a progress monitor can i do
much bigger ones here
like 10 to the 15.
wow is that using the the
asymptotic behavior of the riemann zero
function
guys do we have the person who knows
about this here
um yes i'm here you mean if it use
um
well yes the technique use it but not
explicit in that sense okay it says
progress monitoring so i'm looking
to see progress monitoring and so far so
so so
right now is not on by default so if you
add the option
um progress monitoring goes to throw
okay
well right now it's it's also
uninterruptable as well
see that this is uninterruptible
yes so that's wrong
so i have to kill the curl here to to
get this to work
up finally i bought it okay so if i
said 10 to the 16
why would you have progress monitoring
off by default if it's
if it's some progress reporting or what
i guess for parties
to true um yes
so that's not an actual option name yet
or is it an option named for other
things no it's not
uh yet no is it an option name for any
function
um no that's fuzzy okay so you can't put
this in
for this okay because there's a whole
bunch of functions that are supposed to
have things like this
right so please ask the people who've
been working on the progress monitoring
stuff yes we discussed with them okay
so this is what they want so this is
going to be put into like 50 functions
um yeah they pick the same name i mean
okay can i see the list of functions
it's intended to be put into
um i should probably ask you i don't
have it oh it died
fine so get that make sure that that's
in a meeting maybe an lcc meeting
be there and let's talk about this make
sense
i'll make sure it gets added to the
agenda okay
so i'm sorry just let me see this again
just for fun
what is this doing other than just
saying i'm computing
so it doesn't know the remain is it ever
going to know the remaining time
um yes so this first
what i call it one mean time where we
kind of first estimate
how much operation have to be done
and then after that start to
estimate that there's still some issue
in term of
um you know drawing the focus reporting
background parameter so
how many waypoints are you storing by
default
i mean why don't you store the 10 to the
n points by default
yes so that was one of the things we're
considering because we
i would store the 2 to the n and the 10
to the n by default
did you see what i'm saying yes
are there any other obvious ones to
store i mean obviously you can given
that you have those waypoints
if you say 10 to the n minus one you'll
it'll be trivial to get to that one
right presumably that's how you do it um
yes pretty much
okay
somebody's asking z timothy's asking are
those graph infos manually input no
i mean this this this is all
from our knowledge base of many things
um okay i think
uh let's see
um yeah bob is observing you can use
shady languages to do
even neural net computations yeah we're
aware of this whole
whole weird evolution path of gpus
and uh and the like um
okay anything else we need to cover here
nope i think that that that covers it
okay great
so we're this this area is good to go
for 12 3 is that true
yep excellent all right will i see you
again roger let's see i think i have
another
30 minutes after a different meeting yep
so
it's our day today right it is yeah
okay okay see and to people who are
watching this live stream there'll be
another one
starting in about 30 minutes so
hope to see you then